nine-year-old boys kindness is helping
keep the Christmas spirit alive in a
Southern California neighborhood
this home in Downey just outside Los
Angeles is usually decked out with
elaborate decorations this time of year
but then thieves stole some of them
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn has returned vlad say then
someone's tried to steal Christmas
you're mean one mr. Grinch
whoever did this because neighbors loved
the lights and decorations at this home
that includes Santiago Macias but when a
couple of grinches did in fact steal
those Christmas decorations by taking
the display both this year and last year
messiah's decided to do something to
make sure there would still be holiday
magic in the neighborhood the Jones
family usually decks their house for the
holidays with bright lights and handmade
decorations the whole neighborhood comes
out to see it's all handmade and it's
just it's really really really beautiful
but when thieves stole some of the
display not once but twice I was really
really angry and I was surprised that
somebody would do something like that at
Christmastime owner Nicole Jones was
going to pull the plug I love them you
think I loved all the decorations I just
loved everything but then came a letter
from nine-year-old Santiago Macias dear
neighbors me and my family have a
tradition of going to your house and
seeing the decorations
Santiago included $20 asking her to
continue the tradition
[Music]
and Santiago's reaction proves a little
bit of kindness can really make some
magic warming our heart Santiago the
thieves were caught on camera but never
identified the theme for the display is
The Nightmare Before Christmas I love
that they're all handmade now and $20
for little-kid 20 bucks is like a lot of
money no way that came from mom's purse
baby yeah good job to motivate these
thieves oh yeah thank you very much